this is a psychological aspect of
achieving good pronunciation hi there
steve coffman here and today i want to
talk about natural pronunciation
now if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe click on the bell for
notifications and if you follow me on a
podcast service please leave a comment i
do appreciate it so i want to follow up
on the
fascinating discussion that i had with
stephen crashing the other day and that
was a live stream and you may have
watched it it's available uh here for
you to look at if you
weren't able to participate in the live
stream it is also going to be available
as a lesson
with
subtitles with the the transcript
in our english library at link where we
have a number of videos from dr krashen
that you can use if you're working on
improving your english and if you want
to become more familiar with dr
krashen's ideas
in the conversation with dr crash and he
had a
he has wonderful stories to tell one of
his stories was
that he was in a
french class or he heard about someone
who was in a french class and who was
always criticized for his pronunciation
his pronunciation wasn't very natural it
wasn't i mean we don't have to be
totally native but he was still very
much far away from french pronunciation
he was in a way hiding behind his
english pronunciation
and then for whatever reason he decided
that he was going to impersonate
imitate a french person so he
arrived one day in front of the class
and he put on a beret because people
think french people
all wear frenchmen all wear berets which
they don't
and he pretended to be a frenchman and
you
he was you know we can imitate french
people speaking english like very often
some people can imitate the fragrance or
english but when they go to speak french
they're still using their english accent
so he decided that he was going to
pretend to be a frenchman with his beret
with whatever other disguise he had on
and he spoke french and he spoke with a
very good accent with good pronunciation
and the teacher said where has that
pronunciation been hiding
and of course he was in the mood for
that and so i think we can achieve if
not native-like pronunciation which is
more difficult to achieve but we can
achieve comfortable pronunciation
pronunciation that the native speaker
enjoys listening to even with an accent
that feels natural that is not strained
but
is free of the inhibitions that too
often people feel when they're hanging
back in the safety
of sort of pronouncing french along les
in other words
staying with the less risky
sort of pronunciation of not
making an effort to imitate not to take
that that jump into the what might be
cold water of trying to actually sound
like
whatever language it is we're learning i
mentioned to dr krashen that i have
referred to this
as cultural weightlessness and that this
is a psychological aspect of achieving
good pronunciation there are many other
things that we can do to improve
pronunciation
listening is certainly one listing the
things that engage us emotionally is
going to help us but also
at some point you have to recognize that
you have to sort of lift yourself up
this cultural weightlessness you're not
a part of your native culture now
you in fact are going to try to sort of
immerse yourself
throw yourself into the water into the
culture of the language that you're
learning you're going to pretend to be
one of them
and if you do that
and and i think that's as i said also to
dr krashen why very often actors i
remember once hearing jodie foster speak
french she has phenomenal pronunciation
in her french she makes mistakes on her
gender
so
it's not to say that her french is
perfect but if we are concerned about
pronunciation if we think of an actor or
an actress that has to they're no longer
she's no longer jody foster she is
whatever person she's playing in the
movie and so actors are used to the idea
of projecting them themselves into the
role of someone else and when we speak a
language not only do we have to learn
the words and the phrases and so forth
and improve our comprehension which i
always stress but if we want to improve
our pronunciation if we want to achieve
natural comfortable pronunciation
comfortable for you using it
comfortable for the person listening to
it it needn't be perfect i think that
requires that willingness to play act
to to sort of pretend you're someone
else and once you've done that a few
times that then becomes
the natural pronunciation for you
because you have now moved
as a speaker i use french but it could
be any language you've moved from being
sort of a foreigner attempting to speak
the language to this new role where you
see yourself as
a member of that cultural group and i
think if we can learn to do that
and it's certainly what i try to do when
i learn a language
we then develop what i would call
natural pronunciation which is not the
same as native pronunciation because
realistically it's very difficult to
achieve
a
level of pronunciation that is
where you'll be mistaken for a native by
and large not going to happen however
you can achieve a level of pronunciation
that is very pleasant very natural so
that's my recommendation when it comes
to pronunciation and i'll leave you with
a couple of videos that i've done in the
past on pronunciation you may also want
to visit the crash and interview whether
at the youtube channel here or in our
library at lake thank you for listening
bye for now